une lueur d'espoir pour des milliers de
civils assiégés la vice première
ministre ukrainienne a annoncé la mise
en place de dix couloirs humanitaires
pour ce samedi tous sont situés dans
l'est du pays là où les efforts de
l'armée russe se concentrent en ce
moment même les habitants de cinq villes
meli topol toc mac nerfs audard bézian
et marioupol pourront être évacués vers
apories giat en rouge sur cette carte
dans la région de luhansk cinq autres
villes seront évacués en direction de
bach mouthe dans le même temps le
président ukrainien se dit toujours prêt
à poursuivre les discussions pour mettre
fin aux combats
l'ukraine a toujours dit qu'elle était
prête à négocier et qu'elle chercherait
tous les moyens de mettre fin à la
guerre malheureusement parallèle on
assiste à la préparation d'un combat
important certains disent décisif dans
l'est de notre pays
al'approche de cette nouvelle offensive
les habitants des régions ciblées espère
que d'autres corridor d'évacuation
pourront être sécurité prochainement la
mise en place de tels couloir avait
plusieurs fois échoué ces dernières
semaines moscou avait initialement
proposé des d'aquilée civile ukrainien
vers la russie et la biélorussie
une option inacceptables pour l'ukraine
les autorités ont par ailleurs accusé la
russie d'empêcher les évacuations en
ciblant des convois de civils des
allégations rejetées par le kremlin